oh
oh no no don't rock it please what
happened to you oh nebula who hurt you
oh that's wrong what is that that's
right
no no welcome back to new rock stars
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 will
reveal the origin of rocket and his
scars but by now we know the high
evolutionary Herbert Windham had
something to do with this but how
exactly did Herbie Master artificial
intelligence and if it's not artificial
where did rocket salt come from no what
the [ __ ] hey at the same time
hey thank you this is inside Marvel it's
new Rockstar's weekly Marvel reaction
show we are live here in the new
Rockstar Studio first time the three of
us I've ever shared a set together flash
in the flesh I'm Eric
and Mt welcome to New Rockstar Studio
I'm so excited to be here everybody I'm
going to be so annoying in real life
he pinched the hell out of me no one saw
that he pinched me I said I didn't even
say Pinch Me I'm Dreaming he pinched me
call the police no in today's episode
what we're talking about he said
absolutely not
we're talking about guardians of galaxy
Vol 3. but in how really there's more to
Rocket's history than we really
theorized
do you think
[Applause]
all the time
I liked it though I shouldn't I
shouldn't have sighed I liked it it was
good 10 out of 10. well it's really
reference to the uh the Comic-Con
trailer which wasn't the trailer that
released wide
um that flaming lip song that's not
really the song right now so that was my
mistake one of many mistakes we'll
probably make of this episode uh but
let's start with our question where do
we think Rocket's Soul came from the
soul the soul because it's more or less
confirmed that Guardians volume three
from the trailer that Herbert wind and
the high evolutionary is the the man
behind the curtain behind the origin of
Rocket right and volume two yondu
referred to quote them scientists what
made you a nonsense mush-mouth phrase uh
and at Comic-Con chiquity Ouija in
character and a costume as Herbert
Windham talked about quote dissecting
begins to see what he can learn wanting
to find the perfect being so yeah it
sounds like he's he's part of the
operation maybe he's associated with The
Enclave or Runs The Enclave or maybe he
just did it by himself with his own
group of scientists but you know rocket
is not a raccoon he is an artificial
being he was something else that was
engineered genetically and then
cybernetically enhanced thereafter but
the question is was he born with
artificial intelligence or the capacity
of artificial intelligence
um and what other uh evolved life forms
uh you know or does he have what other
evolved life forms have what we call a
soul because he has the skull and the
brain size of a raccoon right um does he
have enough brain matter in there to
have complex thoughts feelings and
memories that constitute the soul I
think based off what we've seen so far
yes but let's consider some possible
Origins for souls and AI in the MCU
Vision has a soul because he got these
Souls Stone not the Soul Stone the Mind
Stone excuse me the Mind Stone had
artificial intelligence that imbued uh
what we consider a soul to be and then
use Wanda using her chaos magic was able
to replicate that so we have that we
have Celestial DNA and Celestial light
what kind of gives all of us our souls
we think of the MCU but there's also
something that we might consider the X
Gene a violation a mutant Gene a
violation to the celestial uh plan for
all of us do we think that rocket Soul
could have we're going to find out how
exactly he has like complex thoughts
feelings and emotions and memories
yeah uh 100 I think that that's why the
high evolutionary is going to be in this
movie because like we know from
guardians 1 when they're sort of like
scanning rocket um during the the prison
the jail yeah the zandar booking
sequence yeah um you see like his his
like they get a like a scan of his brain
and like you'd like yeah he was
cybernetically and like enhanced and I
feel like we're gonna learn that the
high evolutionary took all these Lab
Rats and enhanced their minds and like
gave him the ability to to feel and to
be and like it's going to be just a
story about the human brain and how like
how it how it ties into Evolution and um
we sort of got like a primer for that in
Iron Man 3 with Killian
um he was like Hey like um the human
brain was meant to be upgraded and I
think that you know considering that
Herbert Windham is originally from Earth
I think that Killian was potentially
continuing Herbert windham's
um research from when he was on the
planet
um and so it's really going to be all
about you know just how intelligent how
like feelings and emotions are tied to a
an intelligent brain with a heart
um in the MCU
um yeah sure do you think that when um
the high evolutionary was creating them
that he also made a situation where it's
like yeah they have their own mind but I
also have a more of their mind like if
they have the left brain he has the
right brain kind of that sort of thing
because I like the idea that um it's
like yeah they evolve their brains but
when you think they'd evolved their
brains to want freedom and to want to be
aware from this man but maybe he has
something that uh controls that portion
of it and maybe that thing is empathy
maybe what what brings rocket back is
like missing Lila or thinking that Lila
might still be imprisoned and he needs
to free her I mean this this kind of I
mean that's a pretty horrifying thought
right that like that empathy is a form
of Shackles on all of us that really
freedom is a Detachment from one or from
me
um but like our connection to each other
is what binds us and and it's kind of a
trap in some ways I think the more scary
part about that is the fact that the
high revolutionary is constantly seeking
the perfect being but he doesn't have
what makes the perfect human being so if
he's missing empathy he's forcing it
upon other people and just being like I
don't understand this and then torturing
them yeah I think thematically that's
exactly what James Gunn's been trying to
tell us with everything he has made is
that our imperfections are is what is
more beautiful about us Perfection is
horrifying and ugly and disgusting and
we should it's not an ideal that we
should Aspire toward but really uh
what's beautiful about us is how we're
flawed right and I think the idea of
Adam Warlock is at the far end of that
spectrum of perfection but it seems like
he's you know the way Will Poulter has
described the character a newborn
infantile he doesn't have that kind of
complex empathy and he's just kind of
like more ID right reactionary
um so maybe that's kind of what freaks
them out is like that that toiling
toward Perfection is really a curse and
really we should just celebrate how
we're flawed and broken exactly I mean
like that was the whole Crux of
guardians of galaxy Vol 2 where it's
like you could be a God Like You could
be a perfect being live forever and then
she's like no I just wanted be human
because like I don't care about being
flawed and being like going to die one
day like this is it's worth it you know
like to have a family and even even if
it's all fleeting yeah are we also uh
assuming that if rocket didn't have a
soul the rest of the other Advanced like
animals that are on that planet also
don't have souls see I had to I think
rocket does have a soul and I think they
have a soul too I was trying to
distinguish because they don't speak
like the common language they have their
own language
um but they wear clothes they get mad
when a girl gets packed in the face with
a kickball so I think they have the same
kind of human empathy the complex
thought like they're able to drive cars
and like understand what mail is because
there was a postal delivery worker
um so I think uh if we're talking about
where Souls come from I think uh
realistically Herbert window must have
the ability to advance a Bean's mind uh
in a way that
um tells us something about what the
human mind is and if you were talking
about like the brain and what did we
learn about about uh ego ego was a
floating brain he was a boltzmann brain
in space we know that nowhere Had a
Brain in that skull because they were
carving out some of that Celestial brain
and spinal tissue so I think while not
all uh beings Advanced beings in the
universe were created in the exact image
of a Celestial body I guess we're all
bipedal in that regard I think we were
all made in the image of celestial
brains because no one like westworlds
how like uh Anthony Hopkins character
talked about the idea of the bicameral
mind right and then uh Michelangelo's
um uh gift of man uh painting the Fresco
at the top of the Peter's Basilica
um the image of God reaching out to
touch Adam he is floating in the shape
of a human brain and it was the idea of
the brain is a gift from the gods right
exactly and so that all celestials
designed all bipedal creatures in that
same regard they they're not interested
in what you look like on the outside as
much but on the inside we all have that
same kind of brain matter the same
bicameral brain that's like two lobes
that are flushed together with an
amygdala and whatever exactly the brain
exactly I don't know where I went just
now no no I I one thousand percent I
believe in this like there's something
I've been thinking about for a while
because the MCU really is tied around
the concept of the human brain and like
how it is so special
um you see it in Guardians too we see it
in Iron Man 3 we see it
um in the fact that you know the Mind
Stone seems to be the most powerful of
the Infinity Stones
um it's like it's really all about the
brain but like since we're all talking
about the soul I'm gonna blow your minds
a little bit do it okay so we know in
Guardians too that the whole concept of
love was how
um in the heart is how yondufu was his
Red Energy Arrow so like red energy is
love and your um yellow energy is the
Mind Singularity of the mind and all
that stuff so red plus yellow is orange
hold on empty back up the how did oh
where did we learn that like he used
love to harness I remember yeah but he
did say it it was like love and passion
makes the arrow flyer yeah yeah I love
that yeah he was like oh I find the
arrow with my and like he gets covered
by Eagles rocks and then like um uh
Peter has that the flashbacks of his mom
and like oh right right yeah yeah he has
the ability to to fight ego so I think
that okay so the soul is like what is
inside right and what is inside the
human body the mind and the Heart yellow
and red and yellow and red make orange
which is what the Soul Stone is and this
is what um Adam Warlock will eventually
I mean hopefully um end up having it by
the end of Guardians and that's why he's
orange and so like I think that like
he's yellow because the The Sovereign
deal with yellow mind Stone energy
Evolution energy which is why rocket
when he first arrived on on the planet
and you saw those batteries he was like
I know what these things are like I'm
very familiar with these because the
high evolutionary probably used this on
me to evolve my brain like this yellow
[ __ ] this mind Stone Singularity [ __ ]
um and I think that's going to be
extremely extremely important for
Guardians 3
um and what is going to tie the
Sovereign narrative to rocket in the
high evolutionary
um is this like the any Lex battery
Evolution energy Harvey Larry batter oh
Harbor yes of course
empty I feel like you're Neo in The
Matrix like after he comes back and
rather than just seeing green code you
just see like different Infinity Stones
exactly right and that's how you
distinguish literally like I only see
the MCU through rainbows it's amazing
what a way to look in the world I feel
like the rolling stone song She's a
rainbow and that's how you look at
everything just through Beauty and magic
and I wish I could see the world you do
um all right we actually uh before we
started rolling we're changing the whole
second half of this show you guys are
into Retreat because like we realize
there's a whole deeper context and
questions that need to be answered about
uh the Guardians of the Galaxy Trilogy
that James Gunn has to do by this third
one so we're going to talk about what's
going to be next to Peter Quill and
what's what story is Left To Tell for
this character
um first we want to thank Brooklyn for
sponsoring this episode you're hosting
guests for the holidays and you're
starting to panic about it Brooklyn and
has you covered from gifts for your
guests to Interior refreshes they're the
One Stop Shop for stepping up any space
when it comes to gifts that everyone can
agree on Brooklyn and is the way to go
they're luxurious Home Essentials feel
as good as they look and offer something
for everyone Brooklyn has literally won
awards for their softest sheets that
you've ever ever felt but they have way
more than just betting they also have an
expanded collection of Home fragrance
the coziest robes and all the bathroom
essentials to make an oasis right at
home they have something for everyone on
your list and with Brooklyn and Rewards
program it literally pays to stay comfy
with each purchase you earn points perks
and Insider info on all of Brooklyn's
exclusive member events and promotions
on top of all the coziness on the
horizon Brook linen is offering
something extra special for first-time
customers visit brooklynn.com today and
save 15 on your first purchase plus free
shipping that's
b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n.com for 15 on your
first purchase uh for 50 on your
purchase plus free shipping thanks again
to Brooklyn and for sponsoring this
episode of inside Marvel okay let's get
into this conversation that we had
before we were talking about like the
character Peter Quill right it seemed
like a big chapter of his story uh his
life story really ended with yondu's
death and finding out that he didn't
need to care about his genealogical
ancestry to Ego uh even like listening
to Father and Son it felt like a resolve
for the character but you want to have
an emotional drive for every character
in a story otherwise you don't need to
be in the movie right
um what do we think is really James
Gunn's end game for Peter Quill and
Meredith quill uh is Meredith quill
going to be the behind the secret the
long lost missing Easter egg that James
Scott had in these movies I uh I'm stuck
on the Meredith quilt part oh sorry I
it's keep believing that scene we see
which we've talked about I think briefly
that scene that we see of uh the blood
and whatever it is and Peter Quill
scream crying is going to be a Meredith
I think he's gonna some like somehow
someone is gonna make him actually see
what the hot like the room look like the
hospital she is whoa so do you think
they recreated it or is that like a
memory thing I think it's gonna be a
recreation of it
oh my God I was like I don't think it's
Rocky I don't think it's anyone that
we've seen yet I think it's going to be
Meredith he's going to lose his mom
again yeah and he turned away before she
gassed her dying breath right he ran out
of the hospital he didn't have to see
her no like no he he was there and then
like she died and then like he screamed
at her dead body and then okay
it's Meredith quills goes calling you
give the phone adjusting he's like
you're lying
[Laughter]
um Peter quills but your question also
is like Peter Quill's full story how
he's going to end yeah what more story
is there to tell because I think exactly
without Gamora other than the search for
Gamora there has to be more to like
Peter Quill especially that they
introduce mantis as his half sibling
you're like well his bloodline is still
important in ways we don't know yet
that's what when you were like I think
this is for mantis to step up and take
the title I think that is maybe like how
this is gonna be fully rounded for Peter
because it is like yeah the first two
movies were about him were definitely
about him and then we get the holiday
special and we're kind of like
I'm getting more from everyone else
every single other character butt him
and it's like yeah he doesn't really
have Gamora and that storyline's kind of
gone and then his family's Situation's
kind of gone but we have mantis now that
is a new part of his family so I'm like
okay maybe we're gonna start shifting
this towards mantis so maybe yeah I feel
like we're um by the end of Guardians
through there there was a huge chance
that mantis could take the the mantle of
Star-Lord
um because I think that the reason why
Peter is called Star-Lord is because his
dad is a Celestial star being like so he
is the inheritor of the star mantle so
like if mantis also is a star being she
can now carry that that mantle and I
think that
throughout this whole trilogy James
gonna sort of been preparing Peter Quill
to be a parent like his mother like sort
of just like replace that role um of I
fill that void
um in his life by becoming like a loving
uh parent trigger like his mother was
for mantis so like where Thor is for
everyone that has a child he now has
fancy well like this is older than you
yeah
I honestly do think that this movie is
going to end with Peter Quill leading
that colony of refugees as a leader like
he was in the in the comics he led a
planet for a little while oh yeah okay
the guard because we hear the trailer
like the the universal needs its
Guardians and I think that that's sort
of at the end where like he's like all
right well I'm retired Universal lead is
Guardian so here's my mask mantis
um you could lead a team of hopefully
all female Guardians could that be dope
I want Lila mantis Gamora nebula cosmos
space dogs like it's going to be Cosmic
places do you are you saying that
Star-Lord will stay on nowhere and then
the rest of them will probably like
we're gonna go find more Adventure
exactly I think that like the MCU
because this is like a universe full of
actors and actors have other um like
commitments and responsibilities the MCU
needs a way to put some actors in stasis
um for until Secret Wars or until like
they need to bring everybody back like
Sebastian Stan in the on Ice exactly
it's like all right
um and I think that Peter cool is just
going to be like all right I'm going to
sit here with like maybe Gamora or like
just be by myself and like just chill
for a while because I've just been
non-stop like being a pirate since I was
a youth and like now I'm just doing
action action action I just need to slow
down and just like have a family of
people that that rely on me to protect
them I like that and so I think that'd
be a nice end for Peter Quill for for a
little while until Secret Wars until
everybody picks up the guns and shoots
each other see yeah I think I like that
idea too that kind of emotional Arc for
well that is kind of the natural course
of someone's growth as a human being I
would say
um not to say everyone has to be a
parent but I think Peter Quill obviously
had that connection to his parents that
he hasn't really fully gotten over right
I wonder if there's like something here
with like I don't know I keep obsessing
over the fact that um Herbert Windham
the high evolutionary could be could
represent what Newton the introduction
of mutant kind that Kang represents the
introduction the Multiverse and dual
timelines like maybe what we've seen in
the MCU the reason we haven't seen so
many mutants so far is that there's been
someone out there like Herbert Windham
and his network of people maybe some
kind of deal with the celestials to
restrain the expression of the mutant
Gene that he has been going through in
his pursuit of perfection he has been
identifying mutants and just like
deactivating the mutant Gene in people
and that's been preventing their their
natural growth from coming about so he's
been going person by person and just
basically saying no denying their mutant
kind through like genetic breeding and
all of these other experiments so that's
going to be the the mission that there's
like more of an assassin mission for
Peter Quill to to take that out like I
wonder if Meredith quill was mutant and
that's why ego like by giving her that
tumor to kind of denied her from being
like a badass mutant that she could have
been Peter learns this and he's like so
how many other mutants have you Stamped
Out of existence
screw that let's uh let's allow mutants
to to exist in this universe so he goes
and takes out the high evolutionary and
now mutants can truly flood that would
be bananas I would really like love to
see like like something like that where
like he The evolutionary is either
messing with Humanity to stop mutation
or to advance mutation
um I personally think it's the latter
because like he's all about Evolution
but like it would be crazy if like he
was just so obsessed with like I want to
be the one to figure it out so like it's
got to be me I don't care about the
celestial but that's living my plan and
my plan for the universe and the humans
aren't ready because I want to be the
smartest human yeah I wouldn't want I
think that the high evolutionary Herbert
Wyndham would be like disgusted with the
mutant Gene because it's chaotic it's
it's in his mind it's uh contrary to how
you breed the perfect species of the
perfect being because you can't control
the mutant Gene it's just gonna take its
own course right so I would imagine him
wanting to like deny the mutant G for
being expressed but like if you think
again James Gunn like this is why I
think he wanted Herbert Wyndham to be
the the villain of this movie is James
Gunn is obsessed with the idea we should
embrace our flaws we should embrace our
Brokenness and our imperfections so I
think that's going to be the Triumph of
this movie is by embracing the ultimate
flaw or imperfection and what is that in
the Marvel world if not mutation right I
don't like that I like that I love it I
just love it with having a team and
having a character like nebula it's like
imperfection is perfect exactly
absolutely awesome that's literally the
whole Crux of the Guardians team it's
like everybody is flawed and like they
come from like really harsh backgrounds
but together they can say the universe
right it's freaking dope and create
something Sublime and beautiful and
something that we need more than
anything exactly
um all right we'll leave it there for
this episode of inside Marvel uh this is
a really lovely conversation yeah
we reached so many different layers of
um thought and uh feelings and um I feel
like I need to just kind of lie down and
process all those things no the other
one person let's do like a weird awkward
side group hug hooray we've done our
hands yes I'm already grabbing this hand
look at my boys
be sure to follow Mt at mastertonment
follow Jessica at Lulu underscore
Clemens you can follow me at eavos be
sure to subscribe to inside marbleware
Brigade podcast uh follow us here on the
new Rockstar yeah on YouTube thank you
all for watching and we'll see you next
time bye everybody
[Music]
foreign